bajar los impuestos a los más ricos una
propuesta que ha provocado protestas
incluso dentro de las filas del partido
conservador forzada y coaccionada la
primera ministra británica que lleva un
mes en el cargo ha dado marcha atrás o
mejor dicho dejo que lo hiciera
suministro de finanzas
hablamos con nuestros selectores y nos
pareció que la idea de eliminar el tipo
impositivo del 45% un día del paquete de
medidas tan sólido que propusimos sobre
los recortes Fiscales para la gente en
general Así que decidimos no seguir
adelante con ello la propuesta de
reducir los impuestos a los más ricos
era una de las medidas del plan del
gobierno presentado el 23 de septiembre
el objetivo era hacer frente al aumento
del coste de la vida y estimular el
crecimiento pero su financiación y su
impacto económico no se han cuantificado
completamente como resultado la libra ha
caído a su nivel más bajo de la historia
y los tipos de interés de los préstamos
públicos han subido esto se suma al ya
preocupante contexto económico y social
recesión inflación por encima del 10%,
explosión de las facturas de la energía
y un gobierno que sobre todo quiere
salvar su paquete de medidas el
crecimiento de nuestra economía Debería
ser nuestra principal misión con este
plan planeamos un crecimiento del 2,5%.
lo hemos hecho en el pasado y podemos
llegar a ese nivel Incluso si nos
enfrentamos a una volatibilidad extrema
en los mercados mundiales Tan pronto
como asumió responsabilidades el equipo
del istrass tuvo que hacer frente a
grandes manifestaciones que se
multiplican en diferentes sectores y la
popularidad del nuevo gobierno
actualmente está en caída